this is the new HTC One it's sleek fast
and if it's like its predecessor it'll
be a hit with intent critics
but does it have a problem who's buying
the Taiwanese company is producing
phones that are loved by experts but
don't fly off the shelves HTC's revenue
has been falling they're hoping this
phone will bring them back to
profitability here I'll mobile internet
the HTC One has a 5-inch full-hd screen
to camera system on the back and what
they're calling the ultimate selfie
camera on the front with 5 megapixels
its software promises to be gentle on
battery life all also being high tech
and intuitive but the competition is
about the heat up Apple a company that
knows how to build hype will release
their new iPhone later this year
according to the blog site macrumors
their new iPhone will have a bigger
screen along with expected camera
improvements htcs offering is expected
to cost close to that of a new iphone so
they're going head-to-head at the top
end of the market will customers fight
anger Spanish Bloomberg